[موسيقى]
تحيات الطيبه الكرام
اليسا
بدات تنافس امريكا والغربه حتى في مناطق
النفوذ الغربيه الحيويه كالعالم العربيه
اليس من السذاجه القول ان الغرب استطاع
تقليما اظافر الصين وفرمله صعودها صاروخيه
في العالم
الا يبدو العديد من دول العالم متحمسا
للتقارب مع الصين والابتعاد تدريجيا عن
امريكا والغرب عموما لم تفقد امريكا
مصداقيتها حتى مع حلفائها التقليديين في
المنطقه الا يبدو طريق الحرير الصيني
سالكا الى كل انحاء العالم سياسيا
واقتصاديا وعسكريا رغم العراقيه الغربيه
لكن في المقابل هل تستطيع الصين اقتحام
المجال الحيوي لامريكا دون ضوء اخطر
امريكي الا تبقى الصين حتى اليوم تابعا
لامريكا وليست منافسا حقيقيا اليس من
التبسيط الحديث عن اختراق صيني للشرق
الاوسط رغما عن امريكا اليس العالم العربي
مرتبطا امنيا وعسكريا واقتصاديا وتجاريا
وثقافيا مع الغرب اليست الصين اضعف بكثير
من منافسه امريكا في الخليج وغيره من
المناطق الحيويه في العالم اسئله اطرحها
هنا في الاستديو على الدكتور عبد النبي
عبد المطلب وكيلي وزاره التجاره المصريه
الاسبق عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من بيروت على
الدكتور رياض عيد الخبيره في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه
نبدا نقاش بعد الفصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس دكتور عبد
النبي لو بدايه معك هنا في الاستديو
الا تعتقد ان القمه الصينيه العربيه
الاخيره في الرياض كانت فعلا زلزال بكل
المقاييس الصين تثبت يوما بعد يوم انها لا
تنافس امريكا يعني بشكل يعني ثانوي اذا صح
التعبير بل بدات تنافس امريكا على مناطق
النفوذ الحيويه في العالم انت تعلم اهميه
العالم العربي والخليج تحديدا بالنسبه
لامريكا يعني لننظر الى ما حدث اثناء
القمه الصينيه العربيه ماذا كانت النتائج
انخفاض اسعار النفط انخفضت اسعار النفط
الى ما دون ال 75$ امريكي المشكله التي
حدثت خلال الشهر الماضي ما بين
وما بين السعوديه او ما بين امريكا كان
سببها التخوف من ارتفاع اسعار البترول
والعوده الى 100 دولار اذا النتيجه كانت
مصالح امريكا هذا الزلزال الذي يتحدث عنه
كان في صالح امريكا اذا قسنا باقي النتائج
سوف نلاحظ ان اكتتابات الصين في اذون
الخزانه خلال الشهر الماضي زادت خزانه ذات
الخزانه الامريكيه زادت بمقدار ملياري
دولار يعني اذا حتى لو حتى ما كانت الصين
من ان تحصل على مكاسب من خلال هذه القمم
فالنهايه او العائد او الفائده سوف تدعى
في الخزائن الامريكيه علينا ان نقرا
النتائج الاقتصاديه النتائج السياسيه
بالتاكيد مهمه لكن النتائج الاقتصاديه
اكثر اهميه المشكله كانت ان ال- ال-
الامريكان في ظل همم الشتاء الذي يهدد
حلفائهم بشكل كبير جدا في ال- همم في
اوروبا والذي قد يجبرهم على التخلي عن همم
الخروج من العباءه الامريكيه هو ربما
مهادنه همم بوتين كانوا يريدون ان يصل ال-
ال- النفط والغاز باسعار الى حد ما معقوله
الى حلفائهم يعني يعانون لكن لا يموتوا
فانا اراه زلزال لكن في النهايه لمصلحه
امريكا يعني زلزال هدم كما اا يعني مدن
ومباني لكن من اجل ان تعمل الشركات
الامريكيه وتعيد بناء ما تم هدمه بسبب هذا
يعني لا يمكن الحديث عن منافسه صينيه
لامريكا بكل المقابر اذا سمحت لي بل
بالعكس انا شخصيا اعتقد ان هذه الزياره
وهذه القمه في هذا التوقيت جاءت بعد وجود
مشاكل ما بين امريكا ودول الخليج حول
تحديد سقف انتاج البترول وكاني وكان يعني
من المقدمات ومن النتائج وكان ال- ال-
الرئيس بنج قد اتى مجرد رسول من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الرسول او مجرد لا اريد
ان اقول وقيل يعني استعير ما تقوله او
مجرد تابع او مامور من اجل ان يجبر دول
الخليج على تقليل اسعار النفط وبذلك تحصل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
المقدمات تقول ثم النتائج يعني خفض اسعار
البترول كان يعتقد انه في دخول الشتاء سوف
ترتفع اسعار البترول وتصل الى ما يزيد عن
100 مليار عن 100 دولار للبرميل ثم تضوج
همم اوروبا من الشتاء ومن المشاكل ومن
ارتفاع الاسعار ومن التضخم يعني يقولون ان
بعض السلع اصبحت مقننه في بريطانيا وقتها
كانت الشعوب سوف يعني والحديث عن محاوله
قلب نظام حكم في المانيا وكاننا في دوله
من دول يعني كل ذلك يقول ان امريكا هي
التي استفادت من هذه القمه بتخفيض اسعار
النفط جميل جدا دكتور رياض سمعت هذا
الكلام كيف تنظر الى هذه التطورات
العالميه الى هذا التنافس الذي نراه الان
بين الصين وامريكا على ضوء هذه التحركات
الصينيه ليس فقط هذه التحركات الاخيره بل
بشكل عام
اولا تحيه لك والديك الكريم
الدكتور عبد النبي على ما شرحه بالنسبه
لزياره الرئيس صيني الى الخليج اذا اخذنا
نحن
باستراتيجيه امريكا
تعتبر ان العدو رقم واحد لامريكا والمنافس
الاستراتيجي على موضوع الاقتصاد وعلى
موضوع التبول مركز الاول في الاقتصاد
العالمي هو الصين واذا اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار الصراع المحتدم حاليا القائم في
بحر الصين وتحديدا على تايوان والرقائق
للالكترونيه والمحاولات همم
الامريكيه بان تحرم الصين من من هذه
الرقائق من تايوان ولذلك خلقت لها مشكله
تايوان
نتاكد بان الصراع على التكنولوجيا العصر
وعلى الجيل الخامس من الاتصالات وجير
السادس وعلى الذكاء الصناعي هو على اشد
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبين
الصين وكل استراتيجيه الامريكيين يعتبرون
ان الص- امريكا قد خسرت المنافسه
الاقتصاديه والتكنولوجيه وتحديدا بجيل
الخامس من الاتصالات وتمدد الصين في مناطق
النفوذ التي كانت تعتبر هي مناطق حصرا
للولايات الامريكيات كلهم يعتبرون ان هذه
مزاحمه كبيره لاميريكا في المنطقه لا ادري
على ماذا استندد صديقنا العزيز في ستديو
بان اعتبر ان هذه الزياره منسقه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
علما ان يعني اذا قرانا نحن ردود الفعل
الامريكيه على هذه الزياره نرى ان جونكر
بمثل ان يقول مما لا شك فيها ان الصين
تحاول ان تتمدد في المناطق جيوسيه
والمناطق الاقتصاديه التي كانت فعلا هي
حكرا على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وانا
بها منطقه الخليج اذا نحن اذا اخذناك هذه
المعطيات واخذنا التصريحات الامريكيه بان
واشنطن مثلا لا ترى هذا حتى تصريحات لا
ترى منافسا لها في العالم بهاء يهدد
النظام العالمي القائم سوى الصين هذا وفق
استراتيجيه الامن القومي الامريكي
ويعني ايضا يعني هناك ازمه كبيره الان
تعصف ما بين الولايات تحت الامريكيه
والسعوديه استغل الرئيس الصيني هذه الازمه
وتمدد باتجاه انا اعتبر من منطقه الخليج
هي الحديقه الخلفيه بتروليا واقتصاديا
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه خاصه ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اكدت في
استراتيجيه المواجهه الصين ان ارادت ان
تواجهها وفعلا وتحاول ان تعرقل تطور الصين
عليها ان تحرم الصين من النفط وكانت تعتبر
امريكا في استراتيجياتها ان منطقه الخليج
العربي وتحديدا المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اا يجب ان في المنافسه مع الصين يجب ان
تحرم الصين من بترول شرق الاوسط علما ان
الصين حتى الان تستورد 51% من طاقتها
البتروليه من من من من منطقه الخليج اذا
اخذنا ايضا محاولات امريكا سيطره على مضيق
ملقه ومحاوله ودف دفع الصين باتجاه
استراتيجيه الحزام والطريق كي تخرج من
التطبيق الامريكي يتاكد لنا ان ليس هناك
تنسيقا امريكي صينيا بل هناك تنافسا
امريكيه صينيه كبيره على كل المناطق وانا
اعتبر ان منطقه الشرق الاوسط بحكم وتحديدا
الخليج العربي يمثل اهميه استراتيجيه
للصين لان فيها مخزون طاقه والكبير والصين
باتت وستصبح في القريب العاجل وباتت الان
هي مصنع العالم وهي اكبر دوله في العالم
همم بحاجه الى موارد النفط كي تمول
الالاتها الصناعيه ومن هنا انا اعتبر ان
لا ليس صحيح هذا الموضوع هناك تنافس على
اشد في مناطق جي استراتيجيه العالميه
وتعتبر من منطقه الخليج العربي احد
المناطق الاستراتيجيه التي كانت ترفضيات
متحده الامريكيه اقدام الرئيس صيني عليها
لكنها لم تستطع جميع نتيجه التنفس الكبير
بينها وبين محمد بن سلمان جميل جدا دكتور
كيف ترد يعني لناخذ المعطيات اول سؤال
للدكتور بيقول على همم يعني الاسس التي
بنيناها ان هذه الزياره يمكن ان تقول يعني
نركز كله على الزياره نركز
يعني اذا اذا نظرنا ان المشاكل كانت
موجوده ما بين السعوديه الامريكيه بسبب
اسعار القمه نتج عنها تحقيق الهدف
الامريكي بخفض اسعار النفط لكن المشكله ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتصريحات
المسؤولين الامريكان من ان الصين اصبحت
خطر هذه استراتيجيه بدات الاجهزه الامنيه
الامريكيه في الاعداد لها بعد انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي بدات الاصوات الكثيره
التي تتحدث في امريكا عن لماذا تاخذون
مننا ضرائب لماذا تقدمون المساعدات
والقروض الى الدول في ما وراء البحر ليس
لنا منهم فائده وبدا المواطن الامريكي
يتحدث عن الحقوق وانه ليس مجبرا على ان
يدفع الا في حدود من هنا بدات اجهزه ال-
ال- اجهزه المخابرات الامريكيه تتحدث عن
ضروره وجودهم حتى يجبر المواطن الامريكي
على الاستجابه لكل القرارات والسياسات
الامريكيه التي
طالع بعبع مصطنع يعني من اجل ان يتم
هناك كثير من من المعطيات الاقتصاديه على
الارض دكتور يعني لا يمكن ان ان ان نتحدث
عن عن بعبع في النهايه الصين يعني انظر
الان الى التنافس الصيني انظر الى معدل
التنميه في الصين انظر الى ارتفاع الجي
دبي اللي هو الناتج الاجباري القومي
الصيني مقارنه بامريكا والى مو هنالك انظر
اين كانت الصين قبل سنوات الناتج الاجمالي
واين اصبح الان جزئيه مهمه في منتهى
الاهميه لكل من يتحدث عن الارقام ويعرف
كيف يتم حساب الارقام يعني جورجينا عندما
كانت قبل ان تكون رئيسه لصندوق النقد
الدولي قالت وقدمت لبعض التساؤلات وهمم
والتحقيقات انها عندما كانت مسؤول في
البنك الدولي كانت تحاول تعظيم الجهد
الخاص بالصين عندما تضيف اليه الناتج
تايوان وناتج هونج كونج يعني الامريكان
كانوا يدخنون
الصين
عندما يقول العدو الموجود امامك ضخم فانت
تستطيع ان تقول لا صوت يعلو على صوت
المعركه وتستطيع ان تقود كل جنودك بدون ان
يتمكن اي احد من ان يرفع صوت معك الكل
يحمل السلاح حتى او يقودها المعركه حتى
وبدون سلاح بصدر اني عارف للاسف الشديد
هذه هي الاستراتيجيه الموجوده في امريكا
اذا نظرنا الى النتائج المشكله الامريكيه
السعوديه كانت بسبب اسعار النفط الحادث
الان حاليا اسعار النفط انخفضت بعد كانت
خوف ان تصل الى 100 دولار الى اقل من 75$
الان حدث حدثين في منتهى الاهميه للرد على
ان امريكا بالفعل تقسم المهام كما تراه
يعني اذا كنا نقول امريكا لا تريد البقاء
في الخليج من كان يصدق ان امريكا تخرج من
افغانستان يعني الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه في
الفتره الحاليه لها معطيات عن المعطيات
القديمه التي كنا نراها الان الاخبار تقول
ان هناك همم شبه صراع مسلح او مشاكل
حدوديه ما بين الهند اليوم
الصين تقول ان هناك مجموعات عسكريه رسميه
من الهند همم دخلت الاراضي الصينيه الهند
وزير ال- ال- بطريقه الهندي في البرنامج
الهندي اليوم يقول ان الصين هي التي بدت
وانها تحاول ان تغير الاحداث العالميه من
خلال تدخلها في الشؤون ومن خلال الترويح
لماذا تريد ان تقول من من خلال هذا المثال
ان ال ال ال الامريكان او الاداره
الامريكيات تريد ان توصل رساله الى العالم
ان ما يحدث يحدث تحت يديها وانها في لحظه
في لحظه اذا اعتقد هذا التنين انه التنين
الحقيقي تستطيع في اقل من لحظه ان تقضي
عليه جميل جدا دكتور رياض السؤال المطروح
تعالى ننظر الى ما حدث للصين على مدى ثلاث
سنوات الماضيه
لو ذهبت الى الوالد ايكونومي المنتدى
الاقتصادي الدولي في عام 2017
نرى ان هذا المنتدى كان يتوقع للناتج
الاجمالي العام في الصين في عام 30 ان
يصبح ثمانيه وثلاثين ترليونا
38,000,000 جاءت كورونا جاءت كورونا لنجد
ان الصين الان تعاني
الصين لا تمتلك اكثر من من الاموال
اللازمه
لتشغيل الحساب الجاري لديها
لو نظرت الى بورصه هونج كونج
من العام الماضي حتى اليوم كم انخفضت كانت
في الماضي 31000 نقطه اليوم 14 15 الف
نقطه اذا الصين كل الكلام عن نهضه الصين
السابق بدا يتراجع ويذهب في الاتجاه
المعاكس مع الاحترام لبرنامج كيف ترد
يعني ما يجري في الصين يجري في العالم
برمته نحن امام
اذى
اقتصاديه هائله المديونيه العالميه تجاوزت
360 تريليون دولار وهناك خوف من عدم
القدره على سداد الديون جائعه كورانا ضربت
اقتصاديات العالم
وبددت نسبه النمو التي كانت متوقع من
البنك الدولي الا ان انا اذا اخذنا ما
يجري حاليا اقتصاديا ان في الصين او في
اوروبا او في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اي اقتصاديات العالم الكبرى اولا همم
حاليا تعيش همم امريكا
حاله من التضخم غير مسموقه ونسبه التضخم
بانجلترا تجاوزت 12% في المانيا
نعم هذا المعلن هذا المعلن اما انا اما
التضخم الحقيقي يمكن طلع فوق المئه
فوق ال 20 لا الميت ههه
لا انا متفق معك هذا المعلن هذا المعلن
لكن ايضا نحن امام حاله تضخم كبيره نسبه
ارتفاع الاسعار اسعار اسعار السلع هائله
جدا الحرب في اوكرانيا غيرت القواعد
الاقتصاديه العالميه نحن امام ازمه همم
ماليا نحن امام اذن الطاقه عالميه نحن
امام الركود اقتصادي عالمي اصاب امريكا
واوروبا ايضا جزء من هذا الركود اصاب
الصين الا ان نتائج اذا دققنا نحن
بارقام صندوق النقد والبنك الدولي اكد ان
النسبه النمو التي كانت متوقع في امريكا
اتليتي ونصف من 100 او 4% انا لا تستطيع
ان تتجاوز اثنين ونصف بالمئه رغم ان
امريكا استفادت من الحرب في في اوكرانيا
وشركات تصليح الامريكيه استفادت جدا وان
نسبه النمو التي كانت متوقعه باوروبا
بحدود ثلاثه ايضا ثلاثه وربع بالمئه الان
قد لا تتجاوز واحد ونصف بالميه والبنوك في
المانيا حتى البنك المركزي منذ اسبوعين
امام ازمه حقيقيه نقديه في المانيا بينما
اذا اخذنا نسبه النمو المتوقع في الصين
رغم كل شيء هذه ارقام البنك الدولي لا
تزال تتجاوز الخمسه ونصف في المئه اذا
قررنا نحن التراجع في الاقتصاديات
العالميه نرى الصين لا تزال الان متقدمه
وحتى تقرير البنك الدولي يؤكد ان نسبه
النمو المرتفعه التي قد تتحقق في العام
المقبل 2023 نتيجه عن التعافي ونسبه النمو
الصيني اذا اخذنا هذه المعطيات يتاكد ان
العالم يمر باذى ما غير مسبوقا حرب
اوكرانيا وهزم الطاقه وازمه ال- ال- يعني
الغذاء العالمي الا ان الصين هي اقلل
المتضررين من هذا جميل جدا بس دقيقه دكتور
خلينا ناخذها دكتور خلينا ناخذها وحده
وحده مهم جدا كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
معدل النمو الصيني الذي يبلغ 5% هو من
اعلى المعادلات الحقيقيه لكن اين يذهب
عائد هذا النمو نتحدث عن شهر واحد
اكتتابات جديده
للحكومه الصينيه اثنين مليار دولار في سنه
الخزانه الامريكيه اي ان معدل النمو الذي
تحققه الصين يذهب عائده مباشره
الى الخزائن الامريكيه قصه على ذلك ان اذا
كنا نتحدث عن هذه المشاكل فهي تزيد الفرص
امام شارك الشركات الامريكيه العامه ما
يحدث في اوكرانيا كلما كثر همم الهدم في
اوكرانيا كلما ضمنت شركات المقاولات
الامريكيه ان يكون لها عقود وعقود ممتده
تشمل على عقود لاعاده البناء او للتاسيس
او حتى بناء البنيه التكنولوجيه
الاوكرانيه او في اوروبا بالكامل حسب المص
الامريكيه عوائد النمو بالارقام اعواد
النمو والارقام تذهب مباشره الى الخزانه
الامريكيه يستفيد من المواطن الامريكي
نتحدث عن 2 مليار دولار شهري نتحدث عن
مليار 2 مليار دولار رسمي يعني هذا ما تم
الاعتراف به وكما تعلم يعني ان الصين الى
سن- سنوات
في اوراق ماليه
تبلغ همم استثمارات الصين او اكتتابات
الصين الحكومه الصينيه في اذون الخزانه
الامريكيه ما يقرب من من واحد تريليون
دولار الرقم بالضبط 970 مليار دولار اذا
نظرنا ايضا على الجانب الاخر وهو
الاحتياطي الصيني من ال- ال- الدولارات
الامريكان تتحدث عن ما يقرب من ثلاثه
تريليون ونصف دولار اكبر بلد في العالم
يمتلك الدولار هو الصين يعني اذا حدث
مشاكل يعني بل ان ال- ال- ال- الارقام
الاخيره تقول ان الصين كانت يعني اشترت
كميات اكبر من او زادت نسبه الاحتياطي
بحوالي 50 مليار ايه همم دولار اي ان
المصالح الامريكيه هي اذا تم تهديدها
فبتنتهي المصالح الصينيه نتحدث عن معدلات
النمو هذا شيء جميل يعني واسمح لي ان اضرب
هذا المساء وكان العبد الذي يجتهد ويعمل
ولكن في النهايه ما ينتجه يذهب
العبد الى هذا الحكم بين الصين وامريكا
هذه حقيقه يا دكتور يعني اذا نزلنا الى
الصين نتحدث عن انه تنين وان الصناعات
تنتشر والى اخره لكن الى اين تذهب هذه
العوائد نسبه الفقر في الصين 34% هل يعني
يوجد من يوجد في امريكا او في اوروبا من
يتمنى او حلمه الهجره في الصين والحياه في
الصين لان الحلم الصيني قد يحقق له
الرفاهيه طيب كم عدد الهجره السنويه
الرسميه الموجوده من الصين الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تتحدث 100,000 الهجره
رسميا غير الهجرات غير الشرعيه هذا مكان
يطرد هل تتخيل ان هذا المكان به من
الاقتصاديه ومقاولات الحياه الاجتماعيه ما
يجعله يستطيع ان ليس ينافس ان يقدم اصلا
مزايا لمجتمعيه او لشعوبه حتى يقدم مزايا
للشعوب الاخرى هل تعتقد ان نظام قمع بهذا
الشكل يستطيع ان ينافس من اجل ان يجود
جوده الحياه لشعوبه قبل الحديث عن تجويد
تجويد الحياه بالنسبه للشعوب الاخرى
مستحيل مستحيل الان يعني الصين وجودها سند
رئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كيف تم
القضاء على الاتحاد السوفيتي عندما قال
الالحاد واني همم يقتلون المسلمين في
باكستان من الغد ارادت امريكا ان تقضي على
هذا التنين الصيني الوهمي تستطيع ان تعيد
الى الاذهان فكره همم الاضطهاد الدين او
اضطهاد المسلمين للاجور اللي موجوده
وتنتشر وكالات الانباء ويستمر هذا في
الاعلام ويبدا الجميع يتحدث عنه وتبدا
الحملات الاسلاميه ولا دفع الرايه والدفاع
عن المسلمين وانا اعتقد ان يعني لن تصمد
على الصين اذا تم غير هذه السيناريو
الفتره التي صمت فيها الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق دكتور رياض كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
اولا استثمارات الصينيه في سندات الخزينه
الامريكيه ليس صحيح انها اثنين مليار نعم
هي
970 او 72 مليار دولار بينما كانت منذ
سنوات
970 كانت
2 مليار في شهر
نعم نعم هذا اولا ثانيا الاحتياط النقدي
الصيني من الدولار انا اوافق مع الدكتور
بانه اكثر من 3 فاصله خمسه
سبعه انا اخر معلومات عندي يعني زدت له
معلوماته شوي شكرا
الا ان الا ان هذه المليارات هي ليس لدعم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه المليارات
اذا دققنا بها
تمجدتها الصين هذا الميرات بعد ان اتت همم
ازمه النمور السفر واتت الكارثه على
النمور الصفر همم
بالقرن الماضي احطت الصين بانها جمعت كميه
نقديه كبيره للرياضه الامريكيه للتفوق من
تقلبات السوق اذا هذه سلاح ذو حدين هو
بقدر ما هو يعتبر ان هذا ينعش امريكا هذا
تستطيع الصين انطرحت هذه التريلونات في
السوق تستطيع ان تسقط
العمله الامريكيه الى الخطيب فهذا ليس
عنصر قوه لامريكا هي عنه هو عنصر قوه
للصين كيف توازن دكتور صالح الصين بس يا
دكتور رياض اذا اسقطت العمله الامريكيه
اذا اسقطت العمله الامريكيه بهذه السندات
الصينيه التي تذهب الى الخزينه الى
الخزانه الامريكيه طيب وماذا عن التلاقي
فاصله كذا التريليون دولار ال- ال- التي
يعني همم
يعني لعبه مش ضابطه بدون شك بدون
بدون شكل بدون شكل انا اقول هايدي احتياط
نقدي لها الا ان النقطه المفصليه اللي انا
برايي يجب ان نركز عليها بانه يعني الصين
تحاول ان تخرج من
التعامل بالدولار
وبالتالي هي اقامت
نظام اسمه نظام صائد سي اي بي اس المالي
وهو بديل لنظام سويف العالمي وايضا الصين
يعني همم
يعني
تركز بشكل كبير جدا على شركه شركه سين
ستاين همم التي هي لها علاقه بالذكاء
الصناعي وهي متقدمه ايضا عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وعن الجميع وقد انتشرت
هذه الشركه رغم العقوبات الامريكيه عليها
ورغم العقوبات على نظام سايبس ورغم
العقوبات على هواوي انتشرت هذه الانظمه في
كل دول اوروسيا وفي العالم العربي و من
احد نتائج القمه العربيه احد نتائج القمه
العربيه ان الصين دعت دعت الدول العربيه
ان تدخل في بورصه اا شنغهاي
وبالتالي تصعر البترول والتبادل التجاري
بيون الصيني
واليوان الصيني حاليا هو عمله تسعير
الاساسيه في اوراسيا العزيز
خليني بس هذه النقطه مهمه جدا دكتور دكتور
ما هي نسبه التداول الدولي للعمله الصينيه
كم اثنين بالمئه زادت شويه يمكن بالفتره
الاخيره يا دكتور تتحدث انت عن اثنين
بالمائه اثنين اليوان عالميا يطرح بنسبه
2% في التداول الدولي بينما الدولار مازال
يحضر باثنين ب 58 بالمئه 58 شو اثنين
بالمئه يعني قد ما عملت قد ما عملت وين
اثنين بالمئه ووين 58 جواب باختصار لو
تكرم صحيح
اولا يعني البترول لم يعد حتى الان هو سلع
الاساسيه انما بالمستقبل
البترول لن يكون هو السلع الاساسيه في
العالم الغاز هو الطاقه النظيفه وكارتيه
للغاز لا تسيطر عليه لا تسيطر عليه
الاولاد تحت الامريكيه وروسيا تصعر كل
التبادل التجاري بالغاز في منطقه اوراسيا
هي وايران والصين والهند والعملات المحليه
هذا ايضا يعتبر ضربه كبيره للدولار
والبترو دولار التي كانت اميريكا متمسكه
به ولعبه البترول العالميه لكي توازن بحرب
الاقتصاديه ضد الدول راينا انه في القمه
في القمه التي عقدت يعني احد النقاط
الاساسيه بنود القمه هي همم بموضوع عمليه
تسعير العالمي بهذا وعدم التحكم في قضايا
البترول والطاقه وترك السوق ان ياخذ مدى
ايضا ضد الاولاد تحت الامريكيه بالاضافه
الى ان ايضا من احد بنود القمه ركزت على
مبدا الصين الواحده وان تايوان جزء من
الصين وعلى امريكا وعلى العالم لم تسمي
امريكا ان تحترم حق الشعوب ان تحترم سياده
الدول واقرب التدخل الخارجي في موضوع
الدول الداخلي اذا اخذنا كل هذه المعطيات
يتاكد لنا ان هناك مناخ عالمي يتغير هذا
المناخ العالم يتغير بدانا بدانا ارهاصات
ونراها في القمه التي عقدت في الخليه
العربي وانا اعتقد ان الزمن الامريكي وان
كان لا يزال تزال اميريكا قوه زمن
الاحاديه القطبيه قد سقط ونحن امام نظام
متعدد الاقطاب تصعد دول الخليجيه والعديد
من دول العالم ان تتحوط بتنويع مصادر
استثماراتها ومصادر العلاقاتها ولان
العالم ولان العالم اقتصاديا مات في الشرق
اتجهت العربيه اتجاه الشرق واوروبا التي
هي شركه امريكا راينا منذ شهر الماضي كيف
ذهب مستشار المانيا الى الصين وكيف
استثمرت الصين 35% من بناء هامبورج رغم
الاعتراضات الامريكيه هذا ان دل على شيء
يدل على ان العالم يتغير وبدا الانفكاك من
من قبضه الولايات جميله والاتجاه الى قبله
العالم الذي هو الشرق جميل جدا دكتور كلام
في غايه الاهميه همم
حمله الاتفاق بين الدول العربيه في القمه
العربيه الصينيه الاخيره تطورا سياسيا
فتطبيقه سيعزز موقع الصين كاكبر شريك
تجاري لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي بدلا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو امر لا يمكن الا ان
تكون له تداعيات سياسيه ينسحب الامر ايضا
على امكانيه تسعير عقود النفط بالعمله
الصينيه واذا نجح العرب في هذا الامر
فسيعات سابقه يمكن ان تستخدمها دول اخرى
اذا نحن الان بدا الكلام انت تعلم في
الماضي عندما يتحدث احد عن استبدال
الدولار كعمله همم يعني يباع بها النفط
تعرف شو بصير فيه تعرف شو صار لصدام حسين
فقط على العمله يعني الان بدا الحديث بشكل
جاد بشكل شجاع بشكل صريح بشكل كذا اذا
العالم بدا يتغير والعرب والخليجيون عندما
يتجهون الى الصين لا يذهبون بشكل عشوائي
يعرفون اين يذهبون كيف ترد يعني اذا نظرنا
الى يعني الرد الامريكي السريع على القمه
الصينيه العربيه وهو القمه الامريكيه
الافريقيه انا في اعتقادي ان هذه يقود ما
يستطيع ان نسميه بانه كان قمه اوروبيه
عربيه
يعني انا لا اريد ان اتحدث ايضا عن
الاكتتابات العرب في سلالات الخزانه
الامريكيه والتي تزيد عن 226 مليار دولار
امريكي منها للسعوديه ما يقرب من حوالي
120 مليار ايه دولار وحدها الامارات ب 45
مليار دولار والكويت 50 مليار دولار وباقي
دول الخليج الكميه همم ما زالت الاكتتابات
الخزان الامريكيه العربيه تزيد والسؤال
المهم هل تستطيع الدول الغنيه الغنيه ان
تامن على اموالها داخل المصارف والبنوك
الصينيه
ام في البنوك والمصاريف الامريكيه
والغربيه لكن في الامريكيه على الاقل هي
في امريكا ضامنه انه لم يتم الوضع عليها
او لم يتم تاميمه او لم يتم الاستعلاء
عليها في ظل هذه الظروف مهما كان ما يحدث
ومهما كان الكلام هو مجرد ضغوط للحصول على
مكاسب لا اكثر لكن يعني في الغرف المغلقه
وتحت الطاوله ماذا يمكن ان تقدم الصين
للعرب هل اتت الصين الى المنطقه العربيه
من اجل ان تعطي ام من اجل ان تاخذ من
تاكيد يعني همم
الصين تريد لمصانعها ان يتم تامين الغاز
وان يتم تامين النفط وان يتم ان يكون هناك
استمرار الامداد في هذه النقطه
تستطيع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ببعض
المرونه كما حدث مع الدول العربيه يعني هي
الاولى المشاكل مع السعوديه والمشاكل بشكل
معين لكن لو هي لو قال لي غدد الطرف لا
ذهب اليها العرب كما كانوا يفعلون ولا
انتهى الدور الامريكي ولا ماما ولا ربما
اعادت الامور الى خلق همم انسيابات النفط
والغاز الى الصين وبذلك يخنقون صناعته
وهذا ما حدث عندما بدات اوروبا تتحدث عن
دور كبير لها على مستوى العالم كانت الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه التي خنقت اوروبا وكما
يعني تحدثت ان يتفق مع حضرتك اني التضخم
الحقيقي في همم في اوروبا يزيد في اوروبا
بالفعل تتحدث عن ال 100%
يعني متى تتحدث عن تقنين البيض في انجلترا
يعني كيف
الامور يعني الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
همم تشدد الخلق عندما تريد ظروف معينه ثم
همم
تفزح المجال وايضا لظروف معينه بس بس سؤال
يعني كيف تفسر اذا هذا الاقبال العربي
اه دول عربيه كثيره في الخليج وغير الخليج
تريد ان تصبح شريكه في منظمه شنغهاي
للتعاون التي عاده ما توصف بطريقه مبالغ
فيها كبديل عن الناتو مصر السعوديه بلدان
كثيره بدات
تطالب بالانضمام الى بريكس تمام بريكس
اللي هي تشكل العدو الاساسي والحقيقي لكل
الاحلاف الغربيه كيف ترد يعني كلنا تابعنا
ما نسميه التطبيق يعني اجبرت الدول
العربيه ويعتقد ان يعني لا احد يختلف عن
ذلك اجبرت اجبرت على ان تعتبر ان اسرائيل
هذا العدو التاريخي صديق وان يكون هنالك
تعاون تتخيل ان يعني بعد الشهداء المصريين
ان يكون هناك اتفاق لتصدير الغاز
الاسرائيلي الى اوروبا عندما يعني عندما
تكون القبضه الامريكيه
هذه القوه يتمنى الانسان يعني يتمنى
الانسان ان يكون هناك بعض
ان يكون هناك ضوء لكن المشكله ان ما يتم
الحديث عنه لماذا يعني ماذا يمكن ان يؤدي
هذا التحالف هل يستطيع هذا التحالف الوقوف
في وجه الناتو الان ما يحدث همم في روسيا
عندما سقط يعني كنوع من انواع الاختبار
صاروخ في بولندا همم يعني الخطا اصلا فقط
اقبال مقصود من اجل ان يقولوا اننا نستطيع
ان ندبر حادث مثل هذا ثم ان يكون لنا
شرعيه لان يتدخل النادي ويبدا في ذكر
روسيا يعني كانت
انذارا واضحا يا دكتور لا يوجد بخطا يعني
من متى تسقط تسقط الصواريخ بالخطا لكن
كانت ال- ال-
التجاوز عن الخطوط المرسومه سوف يكون له
هذه الردود لكن بالتاكيد نحن كعرب نتمنى
ان يكون عظمى ولكن هل هذا ممكن تحقيقه في
الواقع اذا يعني اذا هذا الهجوم العربي
الصين يعني رساله او محاوله للضغط على
الامريكان ان لا تكون في سند الاسرائيليين
الى هذه الدرجه للدرجه التي تجعلها سيده
الرسميه لهذه المنطقه طيب دكتور رياض في
كتابه الشهير المائه سنه القادمه جورج
فريدمان الكاتب المستقبل اذا اذا صح
التعبير عنده يعني قسم خاص في هذا الكتاب
يقول لك كتاب المئه سنه القادمه اللي
بيعتبرها الماء سنه القادمه 100 سنه
امريكيه بامتياز يعني ال 100 سنه امريكيه
راح تضل يقول لك
امريكا وهو انت جورج من يعني يتحدث من
مصادر استخباراتيه بالدرجه الاولى يقول لك
الرجل امريكا لم تفكر يوما بمعاداه الصين
وامريكا بالعكس تماما فيما لو انهارت
الصين او بدات الصين تنهار قليلا
ستهرع امريكا لانتشال الصين من وردتها
الصين بالنسبه لامريكا عباره عن ورقه
تستخدمها في كل المجالات وخاصه ضد روسيا
ضد كذا اذا الصين الصين في الجيب الامريكي
وليس العكس وكل ما يحدث من تحركات عربيه
باتجاه الصين كما يقول لك الدكتور هي يعني
عباره عن يعني خلينا ما نقول لعب عيال مع
ان هي اقرب الى لعب عيال لانه العرب لا
يستطيعون ان يفعلوا شيء انت تعلم يا دكتور
اقتصاديا كل اقتصاديات العربيه مرتبطه
بالدولار وبليورو مرتبطه بامريكا عسكريه
كل البنيه التحتيه العسكريه العربيه هي
بنيه امريكيه يا رجل هل ستسمح امريكا
للعرب و للخليجيين بان يعني يذهبوا باتجاه
التحالف الدفاعي مع الصين وهي تسيطر على
كل شارده ووالده في الخليج وفي العالم
العربي امريكا يعني انت انظر ماذا فعلت
امريكا
ببريطانيا بريطانيا كان لديها عقد شراكه
مع شركه هواوي
الصينيه اه ماذا فعلت امريكا امريكا ضغطت
على بريطانيا بان تفكك كل شريط تابع كل
شريط صغير تابع لشركه هواوي في بريطانيا
ومنعته منعبات مع ان ال- ال- الصفقه بين
بريطانيا والصين كلفت مليارات الدولار مع
ذلك امرت امريكا بالقضاء عليها فتريد ان
تقول لي انه الخليجيين والعرب بدهم يطلعوا
عن فوق الامريكي ويروحوا مع الصين كيف ترد
اولا خلينا ياخذ بالوقائع
[موسيقى]
حين اتت حين اتت الصين الى الامارات
العربيه كي تستثمر في ميناء دبي
اعترضت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
الامارات وحولت ان تمنعها من ان تقبل هذا
الاستثمار الصيني لان شركه هواوي ان دخلت
بنظام جي 5 يستطيع ان يتجسس على كل
التواجد الامريكي في الامارات والمنطقه هل
انتسلت الامارات لامريكا لا لم تنتشر اذن
هذا نموذج النموذج الثاني اتى الرئيس
جوبيد المملكه العربيه السعوديه اثناء
بدايه حرب اوكرانيا كي يؤمن بدائل الى
اوروبا غازيه ونفضيه وكي يضغط على
السعوديه بان همم تزيد ضخ البترول في اوبك
كلاس كي تنزل اسعار البترول منعا لاستفاده
روسيا من من اسعار النفط لي يعني دعم حرب
وترى سنه العسكريه ماذا كانت النتيجه كانت
النتيجه ان محمد بن سلمان لم ينتسل وفي
اخر اجتماع لاوب كلاس طلبت روسيا ان تخفض
انتاج اوبيك بلاست مليون برميل يوميا الا
ان همم ولي العهد او المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وولي العهد اصرت على تخفيض
مليونير ميل يوميا ما دفع اسعار البترول
الى فوق ال 100$ وكانت لغايه الروسيه
السعوديه اسقاط الحزب الديمقراطي في
الانتخابات النصفيه اذا هذا تملم الكبير
من قبل السعوديه التي هي اكبر دوله في
الخليج العربي والتي تعتبرها المملكه
يعتبرها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والرئيس انها دوله منبوذه راينا ان
السعوديه تشرت وذهبت في هذا الاتجاه والان
هذه القمه في كل استراتيجيه الامريكيين
يعتبرونها انها خرق جيوستراتيجي واقتصادي
كبير للحدائق الخلفيه الامريكيه اذا لا
الدول العربيه تستطيع
ان تستطيع دكتور تستطيع بس انا خليني
اسالك كم سؤال بسيط مشان القرب الموضوع
على المشاهده تفضل هل تستطيع دول الخليج
التخلي عن الحمايه الامريكيه هل تستطيع
الصين توفير الحمايه للدول الخليج والدول
العربيه هل ستضح الصين بعلاقاتها مع ايران
الجواب في كل الحالات
اذا كونوا واقعيين في تحليل نتائج اللقاء
الصيني مع مع العرب
لكي اجيبك عن هذا الامر اولا الصين حتى
الان لم تعتمد في استراتيجيهتها بان تحل
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط محل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بمعنى الموضوع الامني
استراتيجيه الصين الان حتى الان هي تمدد
اقتصادي ناعم وربط اقتصاديات المنطقه
بالحزام والطريق وراينا في احد مقررات
القمه الالتزام في ال- ال- ال- ال- ال-
الحزام والطريق وراينا استثمارات صينيه
هائله منها بمدن الذكاء الصناعي منها
بمشروع نيوم منها مصنع سيارات كهربائيه
ينتج 100,000 سياره
بالشهر او بالسنه مع الراس ففي كل هذه ان
اكد على شيء بالاضافه الى الاستمارات
الصينيه بالمتر وفي كل الامور وفي المدن
الصناعيه هذا ان دل على شيء يدل
ان هناك اختراق اقتصادي كبير الصين لا
تريد ان تحل مكان اميريكا الان لا تريد ان
تحل مكان امنيا وعسكريا لانها لا تريد ان
تحمل هذا العبء كما ذكرت حظرتك هي تقيم
علاقات كبيره مع ايران باستثمارات 400
مليار دولار واتفاق استراتيجي لارب- اا
خمسه 24 عام هذا ان دل على يدل ان قدره
الصين في العلاقه مع ايران وقدرته في
العلاقه مع السعوديه تستطيع ان تدخل لحل
المشاكل في المنطقه وهذا ما اكد عنه
البيان بموضوع حل النزاعات بالقطر السلميه
في المنطقه موضوع الصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي بموضوع الازمه في سوريا هذا
تطور كبير لم نعده نحن سابقا في
استراتيجيات الصين في المنطقه اذا الصين
بدات تتلمس طريقه في المنطقه باتجاه ان
تحل بالموضوع السياسي الا ان الشق العسكري
انا معك طيب جديد الان الصين هي لا تريد
ان تتورط في هذا الامر جميل جدا دكتور عبد
النبي يعني
باختصار شديد العرب عبروا عن وجهه نظرهم
هم يريدون عالما متعدد الاقطاب حتى حلفاء
امريكا من العرب بداوا يدفعون بهذا
الاتجاه وبداوا يعني يرحبون بظهور روسيا
بظهور الصين الى هنالك يعني طبعا بين
قوسين العرب مع التعدديه القطبيه مع انهم
لا يسمحون باي نوع من التعدديه في بلدانهم
ولا يسمحون بالمشاركه السياسيه ولا يسمحون
لشعوبهم بان يفتحوا افواههم الا عند طبيب
الاسنان هذه مش مختلفين عليها السؤال
الجميع الان بدا يتحدث عن تم الملك حتى
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني قال اليوم في خبر
عاجل قال يجب ان لا نرتاح
مع تحالفاتنا التقليديه
يعني ان لا ننام على على سرير من من ريش
النعام ونستلقي يجب ان نبحث عن تحالفات
بديله مين
احنا بنعرف انه العلاقه الخاصه بين
بريطانيا والولايات المتحده اذا حتى في
الغرب بدا الغرب يعني في اوروبا بداوا
شويه شويه من
القطب الواحد الامريكي كيف ترد هذا كمان
موجود له اكثر من 10 سنوات
الاحداث على الارض تقول ان امريكا رات ان
هذا التمرين قد يتحول الى اجراءات ومن هنا
يعني هذا يؤكد الفكره التي تحدثت عنها من
البدايه ان ال ال الواجهه الامريكي اصبح
غير مقبول بشكل فبدا يبحث عن وجه مقبول
لكن تحت سيطره اذا نظرت الى ما يحدث في
المنطقه العربيه هذا التمر كان من المفترض
ان يكون هناك تج حول ضروره عوده الحقوق
المشروعه للفلسطينيين هل هذا اصبح موجود
حاليا على العكس الكلام حاليا على قبول
اسرائيل وعن قبول المنطق الشرق الاوسط
كبديل عن المنطقه عن العروبه يعني فكره
الشركه اوسطيه كبديل عن العروبه وان يكون
هناك تنميه اقتصاديه كبيره تتسع لكل
الاجناس ولكل الاجيال اختلاف باختصار بس
الوقت الذهبي شو بدك تحكي بالضبط فانا
امريكا بدات تنفذ استراتيجيتها لكن من
خلال وكيل قد يكون مقبولا بدلا من الوجه
القبيح الذي التقليدي الذي لم يعد مقبولا
في المنطقه العربيه يعني الصين حتى هذه
اللحظه تراها في الجيب الامريكي تنفذ هو
مجرد يعني الرسول ينفذ بالضبط وكيل ينفذ
المخطط الامريكي وكل المعطيات تؤكد ذلك
على الارض
الكرام لم يبقى لنا لنشكر ضيفنا من بيروت
الدكتور رياض عيد وهنا في الاستوديو
الدكتور عبد النبي عبد المطلب نلتقي متى
المقبل فح يعني كان حين وفيصل القاسم
احييكم من الدوحه الى اللقاء يعطيكم
العافيه
[موسيقى]